[音楽]
info voodoo
玉垣かつしたと申します
ボタン等の皆さんもこの仲間の中でですね
お話ができる事をとても光栄に思っています
私はあの子の近くにあります微生物化学研究所というところから来ました
ちょうど目黒とボタンで内でに高速動画
あるんですけどそのうちがそのやません違うのすぐのところにあります
このボタンや後で60年くらい微生物の研究をしています
それが今日の話はですね
微生物はすごいという
薬を作るぴ生物についてのお話をさせていただこうと思います
宜しくお願いします
a 棟マン見せるスプーン皆さんそんなになじみがないと思うんですけど
まずは大きいものならよくご存じだと思うちょっとその話がしていただきたいと
地球上で一番大きい動物はで着替えたら皆さん次に思いつくと思うんです
陸上では寝相大きさで高されたり景品だと思います
準備目を向ける
シロナガスクジラが一番大きい動物です
しかしですね
地球上で一番大きい動物
これじゃないんです実
これなんです
一匹ではないんですか一つの答えではないです
構造物としていちばん大きいですこれは
グレートバリアリーフ
何でできているかと言うとサウンドです35動物なんですね
それが集合体となったこのグレートバリアリーフこそが地球上で一番大きい動物とと
いうことができるわけです
さて消化物はどうでしょうか
植物は一番背の高いこれはカルフォルニア州にある
せっこいだという気なんですけど115メーターあると言われ
これもすごい大きさです
しかしですね
地球上でじゃ一番大きい性別
何でしょうか
植物はみました動物もいましたでもここに後輩てあることは動物でも証拠ですけどない
んです
そうなんでしょう
これはアメリカのですねを高速整備にある
俺と州にあるんですがえっ
このようにきのこ
地中で繋がっているわけです
錦糸た一自治体と呼ばれる
頭の部分はまあ本当に出てる分かるんですけどその中禁止という糸でつながれています
この地域のですね
きのこについて全てに連勝し食べた人がいて
それがすべて一致するわけですそれでこの記録はすべてつながっているって事が証明さ
れています
それでこの記録は
動画日本人がよく好きな大きさの物の例えていますと東京堂605分の広さに広がって
いると言われています
また1500年前から
あるんじゃないかという研究報告もありますね
さあ
こうを見てきて不思議なことはですねこの近郊
実は
さえと金利です信金
つまりそれは日セーブするわけです
微生物じゃあ何だろうってことなんですけど
微生物簡単なんです目に見えないくらい
小さい西武そういうことなんです最近菌ウイルスつ
微細藻類原生動物そんなものが組まれますが
8皆さんが超学校や中学校で
使った光学顕微鏡これで見つからないと見えないようなものが微生物なんです
8ウイルスが格好がしてありますが生物稼働
定義しよってはそうじゃないっていう安定され場合振りますのでは
学校にしています
後もう一つこれでみなさんに教えてい
入って覚えていただきたいことはですね
最近あるんですよバイキンということによってさん使いますよね
そして商人 it 何が違うんだ
ご存知でしょうか
バイキンと言われるものはですね微生物の中で悪いもののことに
ものを生えさせたり人に病気を化させるもの
そういうんだ
銀と言われているんですよく創価学会来たお母さんが
与え合いな栽培についてるでしょっていうなくもあっているんです
汚いものをきれいに貸しなさい
病気にならないに白木をくださいそういうことです
さてこの微生物の大きさを見てみましょう
この下に森がありますけれども合流溝皆さんまあよくアッパ
イメージがわかないと思うんですナノメーターマイクロメーターん非常に
細かい単位なので日常の生活ではまず使いません
人の髪の毛が50から80マイクロメーカーと言われています
しかしながらまあこういうものを
体感するというかどれかへの打つかなぁと new 多分今日は人と
ベスト使ってご説明したいと思います
例えば人がですねエベレストの大きさだったと思う
ウエブスター取り替えるんだ
というとですね年たい一つです
明太の一つ
最近を取るくらい
あずき一つ
そして真琴は
ソフト本溺れ
そういう感覚を覚えていただくとその微生物っていうのがベスト大きさと比べてこれか
えなんだ
っていう風にイメージがなくと思うんです
せっかくですね覚えて帰ってください
さてこの微生物はですね
病気を起こしたりすることもありますがいいこといっぱいできるんです
例えばですね
8を
僕もに系の楽曲の出身ですけど
理系ローダ歪んでい生物の研究をしている研究室がないとかないと思います
医学部薬学部理工学部工学部
栄養学部とか環境学府すべてにリス生物の研究室がありますそれだけスーパー c こと
がいっぱいできるんです
例えばを見てみますと皆さん好きなお酒
発行味噌醤油微生物が作りますし
下水道を敬遠する浄水場では活性を出るというもので環境浄化しています
また樹木を食べたりそういうすることも出ますしエネルギーをつくったり
の中の物質の中間にか変わっています
そんな中我々はですね微生物がいいものを作るぞという力を持ってますね
uo 物質生産する力です
古今注目して
研究重ねてまいりましたいっ
こういう有能部室の中にはですね
微生物が作ってた農機生物をやっつけるもん
抗生物質というのがあります
狭くがそうですけどショッピングカート
日々生物が作って人と人のために役立つようでも抗がん剤になったりそういうもんな
構成ベスト6らっしゃいました
そういうものがいい
35000くらい
世の中にあります
そしてその中で実際に薬品となって
ヒトに投与されて使われているん70種類は何です
微生物はこういう素晴らしいを作る力があります
我々の研究所でも今まで純子薬を作っていました
一番右に生産銀ということがありますがそれは学名で難しいことを書いてありますけど
そういうことが無視してですね
青と黒に注目していただきたいんです
青いものはですねそのまま微生物が作った
化合日そのままの癖になったものです
何も手が加えてないんです
しかしながら黒いものがそのままでは
そのまま薬でならなかっ
人の力科学うちから有機化学の力を少し頂いて書いてそれでもディ by して癖に
なったものです
こうやってみますと前半のものはですね
ほとんどそのまま
しかしながら後半のものが
エットっ
黒いですよねそのままでなく釣りにならなくなっている
やってしまっていくわけですそれはですね
布施ジョン薬になるハードルが高くなってきたんですね
つまり副菜はどんどん酒
達成は隠しできる
薬になる性質
度を高くしてきちんとしたもんでしょうそういうことで私を現在の方ラックス錠
開発するハードが非常に長くなってきていくということです
この中でかなうまいしぶれーお前した須釜維新という
代表的なものがあるんでレンズにちょっと見てみましょう
カスガマイシンというのはその名の通り+がなんですね
加世田対象に土から
この微生物が取られてその後が2時を作ったものです
一番上の写真は
シャーレ6観点上にこれらの菌を
葉野菜をして生育させてー写真撮ったものです
これらのうちは放線菌といわれるものでぱっと見るとか1ルピーています
実際昔はカビの仲間に入れられていました
うん携帯からしかし長らく最近は生物ペンは遺伝子を解析してその分類を決めます
そういう仕事をしていますとこれはカービデオなくて最近の仲間だということがわかっ
たんです
2段目は権利今日は電子顕微鏡の写真です
非常にはまった形をしてそれぞれ違っています
あとす一番下はそれらが作る化合物ですがそれもなく形が違います
先ほどから言われていますようにボタンあの頃我々の中もと同じように
豊泉議員というのはすごく多様性大です
いろんな形のもどんな子
を作る能力があるんです
このような化合物
を月
我々は年見出してまいりました
そしてこの3つはですね僕は子供頃に開かれました
大阪の万博で約5000後1000年後に
a と思います
開けるという大変カプセル揺られています
これはその当時の日本の科学技術を証明するためにこういうものがあったんだぞと言う
ために埋められたわけです
後1000年後の人がこれをどう思うのか非常に表になるところです
さて我々のようなロ薬の作り方の研究を
簡単なご紹介をしたいと思います
我々は
最近をこの作りや癌に対する薬を中心に開発をしています
まずはその病気相手を知ることが一番大事です
ウイルスってはどんなフェイスなんだ
どっか弱点のないんだ
最近殆どのかじゃないここ私のターゲットになるんじゃないかっていうところを探す
わけです
欄にしてもそうですいろんな元もその思う返球している
そのや弱点その成り立ちを研究して標的ように就けるわけです
そのよう的な見つかると
我々は空
力を微生物をとってきてそれを培養してずバイオされたで機体の中たら
と
薬を見いだしていきます
その時に我々は釣り針を使います様々な釣り針をその微生物の培養液の中に
かなと拾うためですねそれらスクリーンと言われている方法ですが
キム金を
抗菌活性を示すものホーガンが性を示す6
様々な家と
例えばある病気になるとこういう骨酵素が体が上がっていること
だから早速このこそ下げてやればいいん
病気はノーだろうという場合はその放送を下げるというようなところを
標的にスプーンを入れます
またある化合物とたんぱく質が結合することによって病気起こるばいい
そういう場合ありますそれをですね
計算が学的に計算してその
エンディング月号を話してあげるとか
ですもそのものがくっつかないんですよそういうことを今
コンピューターでシミュレーションができるようになってきました
そういう種のに使った場合は3位が生揚げにわかります
有機化学の力構造生物学日からそういうものを作って
このいいものをつくったら試してまた変えてというサイクルを回してどんどん磨き上げ
ていくわけです
それによって負債を抑え八性能で使い i 採掘に仕上げてきたわけです
現在我々が一番目指している
大切だと思っている薬の標的は
薬剤耐性菌です
これは今までに我々が作ってきた抗菌剤が
聞かなくなっている理由
それいろんな理由があるんですが一番いいわ
皆さんが違った
その大きい薬の使い方をしているからです例えば
5日で飲みなさい
って言われたものを3日目によくなっちゃったんであと二日間飲まないん
そうすると
薬の濃度が下がった状態が体んだができてしまいます
そうすると上っていきんがいるとその人にもねさらされることによって
薬に慣れちゃうんですね
そうすると第誠意が生まれます
また1日2錠飲みなさいっていうのをもったいない解除にしようということで同じよう
なことが起こります
そうすると体積が生まれちゃうんです
さあどんなとどういう大正義党員メカニズムで耐性菌が起こるかというと
簡単に折れ示していますが例えば
薬のその木そういう設定のブロックすでに体制となりてきてしまうと
木星が入らなくなるような
マークを作ってしまう
あるいは位
一体入るんだけど達者いっていう
そういう仕組みが生まれちゃう
それから降り自体を壊しちゃうって言う
作りができちゃう
そういう機構何度で体勢になっちゃうんです
そういうことになって非常に難しい状況が
なりますので国補いろいろと対策を取っています
8日本の政府が2016年打ち出した大作ですけど
残念ながら新しい薬を作る研究開発ウェイ後場面です
一番大切なのかというと
まあ今日僕もここで皆さんにこういうことをお話ししていますけれども
普及活動教育それを一番下にしなさいということです
元ラムをこれに関わって手伝ってくれています
しかし抗菌薬が正しく使えば非常に素晴らしい曲です
先生が先ほどは高度成長の話をしましたけれど
ここでも1940年だな10年くらいある
抗菌薬が開発されたことによって日本の平均締めはどんどんあります
肺炎リスト一角で死ぬ人がいなくなりました
これによって
平均値が上がったわけですこういうことに非常に
知っ適切に管理してきたんですから最近ではこういう抗菌薬
開発されも難しくなっています
これは日本とアメリカの例ですが日本でもアメリカでも合計約
なかなかできなくなってきてしまう
それはなぜだろうということで
大きいのが儲からないんです
薬という人の命を助けることができますが全世界的に
結局最後は製薬会社が作ることになります
と言うとエコノミカルの問題になっちゃうわけです
あくまでも製薬会社も会社ですから
儲からないことはしません
抗菌薬作るが無薬作ったはいいですよねそれから先ほど歩いています抗菌やっぱ人に餅
を助けるんです
ひょっとしたら一回のことできる
その効果を示してしまうかもしれません
しかしながら慢性疾患について
は高血圧の薬糖尿病の月
そういうのはずっと見続けるわけですそうすると
どうでしょうかどちらももう枯れたというとそっちに目が向いてしまうわけですね
そんな中でも我々の元気ジョイは今もいくつかの電球をし続けています
まったくどんな曲もいかない小多剤耐性の別格に対するくるん
交尾ロリ金でもこれも大勢の日ロリっ子に対するする
あとはもともと普通
a toast ん
大きな危険福井 gram negative となるとそういう間に対する金
開発しております
今今日はですねいろいろミックスについてちょっとお話ししたいと思いますが今皆さん
がピロリ菌を除菌する
例えば伊賀ゲーになりやすいですね1力が入るとそれでいろいろネット直径しましょう
ということになります
そうすると本文俺チェンちゅるんですがこれを7日からもに続きます
そうすると
まぁちょっとできる確率8割ぐらいです
しかしながら耐性菌がいたりすると失敗する人もいるわけです
そしてこの場合抗菌薬にサイト
いのさん押さえ曲これに全部飲まないと効果はないんです
しかしは微生物が作った化合物から
いう金融企画の力でも自慢したものがいつの研究所に開発中です
これはまあ動物実験の段階ですが
ピロリ菌だ下宿んです他の金全青協ないです
つまり
先ほどの曲は飲んだ時に
胃の中とか腸の中にいます最近の影響がたらもあるのでやりがおきたい
便利がおきたいいろんなことを置きますただしこれは大来ません
そんなとこでブロンクスでは非常に力がある曲だと思って思っています
しかしながら先を止めているように新しい穏健派かなかなか難しいです
微生物の力を信じで新しい薬を作っていくんですけど
今後政府援助者
この薬を作っ使った形は何かのそういう
許せんというも与えるとか
あとはた服もう少し高いやっとつけていただくとか新しい一種で積んでる
例えば
必要なに開発できないし電話を払しょくするために
素晴らしいアイデアがあると言うと思っています
また大きなファンディングなどから
いただけると思う開発は全くと思います今日はどうもありがとうございました
ん
[拍手]